to make it big in Hollywood you got to
get your start somewhere and for these
celebs their start with reality TV
everyone on Danny directo with ET Now
I'm still shocked but I'm even here so
it's it was great he's amazing Emma
Stone is a big movie star now but in
2004 she was going by the name Emily
stone on the competitive reality show in
search of the new Partridge Family you
people are freaks okay and I mean that
in the kind of sense of the word Emma
went on to score leading roles in
blockbusters like the amazing spider-man
2 and the help just like she dreamt
about in 2004 I just have wanted to act
my whole life so that's what I'm really
trying to focus on acting stuff like
that julianne hough was a fan favorite
on Dancing with the Stars and use her
talents to score lead roles in films
like Footloose and rock of ages I've
been so blessed to have the fans that
I've had I mean they literally followed
me from Dancing with the Stars to each
one of these facets in my career and you
know it it looks really like oh wow that
must have just happened but it's been a
lot of it's been a lot of tough work and
hard work and that i love that NeNe
Leakes found fame on the Real Housewives
of Atlanta Bob a hater she wasn't shy
about wanting to build an empire landy
recurring roles on both glee and the
short-lived sitcom the new normal NeNe
Leakes is not just a reality star I am a
mobile I am an actress I am a producer
I'm a clothing designer so yeah you had
it American Idol helped launched many
careers including Katharine McPhee's she
actually seen bigger success as an
actress than as a singer it's been an
amazing platform Jennifer Hudson didn't
win season 3 of the show
but she did go on to win an Oscar for
Best Supporting Actress in Dreamgirls
actually the first time I ever performed
on this stage was American Idol finale I
remember sitting it out of time I never
would have guessed that I would actually
win an Academy Award on his fame stage
pretty little liars star Lucy Hale first
wild audiences on the American Idol
spin-off American Juniors
so adorable and Lucy's still singing she
just released a country album for ET now
I'm Denny director